[Music]
drop this little device onto the ground
and it will slowly start to bury itself
this invention is based on self-burrying
seeds found in nature and it could be
used to help fertilize crops or replant
forests
if you want to plant crops or trees over
a big area sometimes it's easier to drop
seeds from the sky this can be done with
crop dusting planes or even drones
but it's not very effective seeds often
get dehydrated or even eaten before they
can germinate so a team of researchers
set out to design a carrier for seeds
inspired by Nature's Own Solutions
this erodium seed has a number of
features that help it bury itself into
the soil away from predators and
sunlight
the coiled drill-like shape helps it
move through the soil small hairs stop
it coming back out again and this long
tail coils when dry and unwinds when wet
helping twist the seed down into the
dirt
this was the basis for the team's new
artificial seed carrier design
they made it out of wood which is stiff
biodegradable and bends depending on
moisture and humidity just like the
seeds
after experimenting with different
shapes they found that a three-tailed
design is particularly effective on a
flat surface propping up the coils at an
angle to be able to better drill
downwards something the single-tailed
erodium seed isn't so good at
to test their seed carriers the
researchers had a go at dropping them
from drones and had them carry plant
seeds to see how many would germinate
in nature different seeds have different
shapes and geometries based on the
different environmental conditions they
have to deal with the team think that
their basic design could also be
adjusted for different conditions
they've already tried a few variations
such as a larger version to carry big
pine tree seeds and a deeper burying
version to carry dark loving nematodes
which are used to boost plant growth
foreign
if they can figure out large-scale
production of their devices the
researchers hope that they could be used
for agriculture reforestation and
dropping sensors for environmental
monitoring
[Music]